bazire a valsé ça va le tout excuser
l'écouté ajoute juge très en colère vous
savez qu'à chaque fois que je fais un
blog dans ma vie c'est qu'un problème
c'est que quelque chose me fait chier et
aujourd'hui n'est pas exception je
marque et un blanc joubert aujourd'hui
il n'est pas question job no il est
question de ce [ __ ] de toulouse de
merde ça se passe que j'ai un gros web
alors arrêtez des loyers du pq de dire
que c'est parce que je me masturbe me
masturbe était que je le jette après ça
fait 3 heures que je m'entête à faire
marcher cet objet alors qu'il vient
juste pas moyen voilà il faut arrêter
des 31 jours et il faut passer à autre
chose
voilà j'ai installé toutes les versions
de l'oculus configuration je sais pas
quoi de mon cul et comme vous pouvez le
voir il n'est toujours pas détecté c'est
hyper intéressant ce que je raconte plus
tard le youtube français veut savoir ce
qui se passait en cette journée quoi je
suis parti je reviens au j'étais donc
j'essaie sur mon ancien pc ça marche pas
elle fond d'écran c'est mon logo puisque
gt gt1 bosse à l'époque voilà je loue
belge fait beaucoup mais c'est un fait
voilà je parle pour rien dire parce que
j'en ai pas c'est au pied n'a pas voulu
marcher je suis en total psg passé
l'après va vouloir faire des vidéos sur
un jour une culée ce qui va intéresser
et j'ai pas réussi en plus je me suis
dit que les yeux parce que vu que l'opus
n'était pas calibré pour bien voir
dedans il fallait que je louche un
plaisir comme ça donne sa voix
c'était vraiment super donc la petite
migraines ophtalmiques me dit bonjour
actuellement dans l'objectif devrait y
fait son kill où j'ai le biceps faible
ça vous le savez ça aussi ça marche pas
non plus de ce côté là et tout coup j'ai
mal pourquoi tu vas pas aidé djombo
pourquoi tu met jamais en tout cas
aujourd'hui bonne nouvelle et sigean
jumbo sera compliqué dans toute cette
merde et ce malheur ce soir je vais
chercher
khawaja renforcé avec intérieur en
plastique supérieur n'a noir un chien
adéquat qu'un chaton passé glisse un
petit lit douillet avec matelas
renforcée bienvenue à chier égale elle
lui achète
voilà c'était aux souris en place
renforcée à moussa sy voilà c'est la
pièce dans laquelle tu survivras pendant
quelques jours le temps de bien habitués
à cette nouvelle maison et à ce second
charpy et vénère prennent du repos il
déconne imposant 1
il n'est pas gros il hilare posant c'est
tout voilà serait bon de les ajourner
j'ai hâte d'aller le chercher
bon du coup il fallait que ça tourne
aujourd'hui le bug de l'oculus parce que
derrière il ya une bonne nouvelle ça va
on est content au moment où je m'étais
cette vidéo en ligne j'aurais pas encore
le chien mais je voudrais créer des jeux
vous même très haut et c'est un
gouvernent mais je voulais te des photos
sur twitter si vous voulez voir voilà
parce que les chats c'est la vie life is
4 you know i'm in moi je suis là ganesha
voilà si quelqu'un vous un problème je
baise et ben j'en ai dit que j'allais
beaucoup m'aider dans cette vidéo
cette vidéo nul on va l'appeler la fille
très nul du 8 février c'est tout pour
moi ça m'a fait plaisir de vous parler
aujourd'hui malgré tout et postaux
demain pour une vraie vidéo assis les
deux pc ne me lâche pas en même temps
alors sauté dans une prochaine vidéo et
n'oubliez pas vive le [ __ ] de jus de
citron aller 3-2 en pls avec un petit
tout pour protéger le coup voilà on est
bien à plus